ciao e benvenuto in un nuovissimo video
allora l'altro giorno salvo andata a
tagliarsi i capelli e per la prima volta
da quando stavi teme non mi sono accorta
che si era tagliato i capelli cosa che
di solito succede alle donne
quindi ho pensato di fare questo video
ribaltando i ruoli quindi invertendo e
facendo comportare gli uomini da donna e
le donne da uomini
buona visione
questi pantaloni mi stavano darvi nello
scorso sono ingrassato come ma non
maiali roba ma che qui anche le
operatrici tendine flaccide ho il fisico
di un cinquantenne amore te l'ho detto
mille volte iscriviti in palestra ad
allenarti cern è difficile allora non sa
che sono grasso allora dove di alimenti
c'è una bugiarda lo sa che lei questa
cosa mi fa stare male ma poi ti sei mai
pensato niente mare e diamo soldi del
castello da me ma a me piace lo stesso
come chiesto un po i due lei ha detto
che questo dentro nota che non sa non
certo poi c'è il 2 con amore
vuoi fare un po di tutti
[Musica]
non sto riportando sì però sai che sono
poi capisci il 2 1
no dai inseriti in questo episodio
aspetta aspetta aspetta quello che
quello che non ho mai fatto altro
sorriso una cosa tutto gli occhiali
tanto gli occhiali un attimo mi cerca e
trova senza ok 9 rimettere i tweet
orgoglio in ospedali mentre i turisti è
così ok dotato è normale che sia
pubblico ma che cosa hai niente a un
sicuro ho detto che non ho niente io
allora esco un attimo e ci sentiamo dopo
poi ci aggiorniamo ok ciao vai vai a 52
michetti e beyond rosso emulato per sé
quei light light like me non mi piace 1
nightlife live faccio vedere io vada
nella pa che può starci male ma cos'è
sta roba che in faccia come cos'è una
maschera di ultima generazione bava di
lumaca indiana tonificante le virgolette
ci toglie vent'anni credito di patate
sospetto secondo solo secondo come ho
già detto è stato un attimo guai e musa
kusa più aspetta amore quale metto due
quella che vuoi sono uguali ma come fai
è da confondere il verde mimetico col
verde oliva e col verde pino male bye
bye che meglio va in pace da solo
[Musica]
mamma mia e allegria
ma direttamente su un filo d'olio po di
tono il vostro suona dieta ma anche qui
a vivere con quella della marina ma
vattene in camera amore mio ti accorgi
niente è cambiato tutto palma no più ho
accorciato questo ciuffo non è ma non si
vede neanche amore c'è scusami eh come
no
205 cm e l'autostrada non mi sono
accorto che mi dai per scontato non mi
guardi più note interessi più di niente
per questo che non ti accorgi di niente
amore andiamo si riesce sono a tenere
questa volta da bari
amo non so dove mettere tutto più strano
ma se tutto buona idea cavolate o poi
pesa giuro che poi si pensa che lo porto
io spero questo solito ok
eccoci purtroppo arrivati alla fine del
video fatemi sapere con un commentino
piuttosto fuori di queste scelte vi è
piaciuta di più se non avete ancora
fatto
ricordatevi iscrivervi al canale e di
cliccare sulla campanella che trovate
vicino al tasso d'iscrizione per
rimanere sempre aggiornati su tutti i
miei vi deve essere i primi a commentare
e soprattutto seguitemi su tutti gli
altri social instagram facebook e musica
ciao
[Musica]